ottawa has a new soundtrack
as protesters move to surround the
parliament a movement spurred on by
truckers makes itself heard
as the signs make clear this is a
reaction to covid restrictions mainly
because canada and the u.s now say if a
trucker wants to cross the nearly 9 000
kilometer long border they have to be
vaccinated the canadian transport
minister joined al jazeera to defend the
policy
we have mandated a vaccine vaccination
for transportation sector for the
airline sector for marine sector for the
rail sector last fall and we've done it
successfully so now almost 99 of workers
in those sectors are fully vaccinated
that has reduced infection rate that is
reduced hospitalization that's reduced
absenteeism and that added resilience to
our supply chain
there are reports that canadian prime
minister justin trudeau and his family
were moved to a secure location out of
concern and the police chief said he
felt he needed to bring in extra
officers the risk factors extend beyond
the core demonstrators to those that
have already indicated
online and in other forums that they're
prepared to engage directly or
indirectly with the events that will
transpire over the next several days
here and some of them have been very
clear in inciting hate
um encouraging acts of violence and
criminality
there were no reports of violence early
saturday but there was plenty of
profanity-laced signs and strong
opinions expressed i understand the
pandemic is a problem however we're
going to look around us and see also
what we're doing
when we're implementing all these these
mandates you know we cannot we cannot
kill the patient in the name of curing
them we cannot do that guys
so we're gonna stand free that's what
we're gonna do
the question now when will this stop
it's a well-funded protest raising more
than eight million dollars on gofundme
meaning
this may be the sound of the city for a
while to come
paddy culhane al jazeera